حينما
السماوات
لا ينجم
[Silence]
بسم الله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد
ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد ان رياض الصالحين
باب فضل يوم الجمعه ووجوبها والاغتسال لها
والتطيب والتبكير اليها والدعاء يوم
الجمعه
والصلاه على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فيه
وبيان ساعه الاجابه واستحباب باب اكثار
ذكر الله بعد الجمعه
جمعه
يقول النووي رحمه الله
وعنه يعني عن ابي هريره
عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال الصلوات
الخمس
والجمعه الى الجمعه
ورمضان الى رمضان
مكفرات
ما بينهن اذا اجتنبت الكبائر رواه مسلميره
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه
‏Friday
all
expator of sin for that which falls
between them
provided that the ma sin
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان تجتنبوا كبائر ما تنهون عنه نكفر عنكم
سيئاتكم
وندخلكم مدخلا كريما
سبحانه وتعالى سوره النساء
‏mait
we will expate from you from upon you
your sin
and so
what we understand from this
‏sin
while ading to the ma
and comm of
these act as expator of sin for that
which falls between them
so we have weekly
‏daily
and
we have the daily
expiator of sin the daily prayers
the weekly expiator of sin one to the
next and we have the yearly expiator of
sin
to the
‏acts of worship are so beloved to Allah
so
hold so much merit with Allah that if a
personulfs
these oigations
and refrains from major sin
these will expiate the sins between
‏away paron for
erase the sins that fall between them we
know that this is for minor sin how do
we know it's for for minor sin
because he says
that we have to
avoid maor sins in for these to be or
act as an expiation
مكفرات اي مكفرات
لصغائر الذنوب
الله عز وجل يسمي
الصغائر في القران فيقول اللمم
اللمم
يقول سبحانه وتعالى واصفا
ا اهل الايمان واهل التقوى
الذين احسنوا يقول تعالى
الذين يجتنبون كبائر الاثم والفواحش
الا اللمم
ان ربك واسع المغفره
الله describes
the people ofan
as those who refrain from the major
prohibitions
they refrain from the major
sins
and then he mentionsam
here
is an interesting word to be used for
minor
‏Arab lang
past verb
and
is gather something to accumulate
to min asulation
little things on their own are not
‏notstal
but they haveit
they haveit
of gathering and stacking on
until they make
until they become bigger than a major
sin
and so we are in desperate need of these
minor sins being
‏question here
is what is
ma
if we want to understand this narration
and trly impement it we have identify
and define what a ma sin is
that's
where the meets the road here this toic
السؤال
ما هي الكبائر؟ الله عز وجل يذكر الكبائر
في القران يقول
الذين يجتنبون
كبائر الاثم والفواحش
ويقول تعالى ان تجتنبوا
ك ان تجتنبوا
كبائر
ما تنهون عنهم نكفر عنكم
[Silence]
accurate
of sin
is
back to عباس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابن عباس
ترجمان القرانس
ما يفيد
[Silence]
يقولون
والراجح عند العلماء عند المحققين
ان
الكبيره من الذنوب
ما كان له عقوبه
خاصه به
من حد
او وصف
او عذاب
في الدنيا او الاخره
sin
that come of
‏by
being seed et
or
here
this will
propes
‏gra
the couldn
himself
like
that it is the sin iser to as a type of
fuj or f or whoever does it is
considered to be a جر اور الفاسق اور ا
يكون استبرا منه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
او قال ليس مني او ليس منا الى اخره من
هذه الالفاظ
any
punishment
‏other
designated punishment sin this iser to
as a minor sin
and ‏So if you understand that
that definition and you apply it, you'll
be able to rather easily
differentiate between major and minor
sins. ‏And so when a person refrains
from these major sins
and fulfills these major obligations
one of the merits and the
is that it
fall between each
week.
ان يكفر عنا سيئاتنا وان يتوفنا مع
الابرار واذا اراد بعباده فتنه ان يقبضنا
اليه غير مفتونين والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد